-I'm in the giving spirit.
I'm in the giving spirit
tonight.
I mean, why does just one person
get a gift? Why --
[ Cheers and applause ]
Why can't everyone
in the audience get a gift?!
[ Cheers and applause ]
That's right! It's time for
"Tonight Show"
Stocking Stuffers!
-♪ Hey, girl ♪
♪ I wanna be your midnight
stocking stuffer ♪
♪ H-e-e-e-ey ♪
-Every night
until Christmas break,
we're giving away
an awesome gift
to every single person
in our studio audience.
You guys want to see
what you're taking home tonight?
[ Cheers and applause ]
Questlove, drum roll, please!
[ Drum roll ]
Tonight's stocking stuffer is...
-Ray-Ban Meta smart glasses!
-That's right, Jimmy.
Ray-Ban and Meta
blended their iconic style
and cutting-edge technology
in their brand-new
smart glasses.
Now you can capture your story
and share your unique POV
hands-free.
With a built-in
12-megapixel camera
and a five-mic system,
you can record
life's best moments,
make calls, listen to music,
live stream,
and ask Meta AI while staying
in the present moment.
Jimmy...
-That's right!
Thank you, Meta,
for providing these glasses.
Stick around. We'll be right
back with more "Tonight Show"!
♪♪